our colleagues at CBS Los Angeles and
their viewers witnessed a very scary
moment over the weekend it was on the
air KCAL news meteorologist Alyssa
Carlson fainted live on air Saturday
just as she was about to deliver a
forecast a warning some of this video
you're going to watch is difficult to
see
meteorologist Alyssa Carlson she joins
us live in the studio Alyssa this really
is the Calm before the storm not again
no oh
Alyssa was checked out in the hospital
the good news we are very happy to tell
you she is okay we can see that for with
our own eye she joins us now from
Bakersfield California here at the table
of CBS News chief medical correspondent
Dr John Lapu is here to help us all
better understand exactly what happened
to you Alyssa good morning we are so
glad to see you can I just say you gave
us such a square such a scare the people
who love you the people that don't even
know you were thinking is she going to
be okay so take us to that moment did
you feel anything amiss that Saturday
morning as you were delivering the news
well thank you Gail and everyone um
there's at the table you know in the
morning I felt fine
um it wasn't really up until about 15
minutes prior to the incident that I
started to feel a little nausea and at
that point I went to the restroom and
thought okay I I'll be fine I'll get
through the hit and I'll get something
to eat because I hadn't had breakfast
that morning I also had been drinking a
lot of coffee and so most likely I was
maybe a little dehydrated so at that
point I thought I'm just going to power
through I'll be fine as I usually am
well yeah I always do Alyssa we power
through what did your doctor say
ultimately caused this
well you know in the past I have been
diagnosed with a leaky heart valve so
initially when this happened I think a
lot of people including myself thought I
was having a heart attack on the air
that was not the case thankfully and
heart tests proved that I'm fine my
heart is great and there's a thing
called vasovagal syncope and that is the
condition that I have I do have a
history of fainting it's just when
you're on a public platform sometimes it
happens and people now see this so it
hadn't happened in a while and I'm now
going to have to learn how to really
recognize the symptoms of this condition
yeah well we're glad you're doing okay
Alyssa Dr lepuc she mentioned a Vaso
vagal syncope if I have it right it's
quite a mouthful what is it all right
syncope is blacking out Vaso is blood
vessel and vagal refers to the vagus
nerve and if the vagus nerve is
overstimulated or inappropriately
stimulated the pulse rate can go down
and the blood pressure goes down and not
enough blood goes up to the head and you
can faint and we saw with Alyssa she was
sort of propped up so she couldn't go
flat and then eventually she went it
looked like she it looked like you tried
to steady yourself and then you just
felt flat over you just totally passed
out
so it seems like you felt so I could
feel that yeah I did I could feel the
tunnel vision coming and just starting
to get black and so I tried to hit the
you know brace myself on that desk but
no it was too late and in all honesty
what I probably should have did was just
not been at that wall for the hit when I
started to feel something come on maybe
just go and sit in the chair and just
let them go to me and take me with
nothing there
that leads me to the question do you
have symptoms yeah very often there's
warning you may get sweaty Palms you may
feel that tunnel vision that's graying
out you're dizzy and people like
especially in this situation you're
embarrassed right I'm gonna just I'm
gonna sit up and look normal that's the
worst thing you can do you want to get
flat so your heart is at the same level
as your head and it's it's pumping the
blood this way not like on your back
maybe your legs up if you can get it
your head to the left in case you vomit
and that's something that people tend to
especially if you're about to go on the
air that's the last thing you want to do
yeah so Alyssa you're also a health
coach uh given what Dr LaPook said about
recognizing the signs
um what would you recommend to your
clients the people that come and listen
to you going forward
well I would definitely say stay
hydrated which I always do tell my
clients and sometimes as a coach we pour
into a lot of other people and we tend
to leave ourselves last so I recognize
that I've had this passion for health
for many years and I continue to strive
for ultimal health Ultimate Health and I
also
um I would tell them one get enough rest
make sure you're hydrated and take care
of yourself as I was talking to the
camera person this morning I said
sometimes we put ourselves last we go go
go until something happens and then
Alyssa have you looked at the tape
yourself have you seen it
I have many times yes yeah yeah please
be careful next time doctor we say Do
not power through right don't power
through it's very very frightening and
make sure that you do get evaluated
because there are other causes of
faintings yeah and I'm picking up my mug
uh because I'm gonna stay hydrated wake
up in the morning you're dehydrated in
general it's true yes Mr Carlson we are
so glad you're doing okay today and Dr
thank you very much for explaining it
all to us we appreciate